what's going on guys today i have a
little bit of breaking news for you and
that is that the black clover anime has
been announced that it will be ending
on the 30th of march of 2021 so this is
uh
pretty much breaking news coming from
crunchyroll and the official black
clover twitter account as well
and uh yeah episode 170 will be the last
episode
so the day i put this out there i think
um what is it episode 162 is coming out
and yeah so that means in eight episodes
time is gonna be done
like permanently it seems um but if we
just look at the announcement here it
says
after 170 episodes the tv anime
adaptation of black clever will be
coming to an
end the final episode of the tv anime
series will be airing on that date
alongside a special afterward to
celebrate the series
and a big announcement for the franchise
regarding that big announcement that
they're talking about
i mean potentially that could be a movie
of some kind because i know you know man
readers will know right now the anime
rather the manga is getting super
intense so you could put this stuff into
a movie potentially to end the series um
but
uh i don't know this is really
disappointing to me though like black
clover
i gotta say it's one of my favorite
series like the characters the main cast
are all lovable
the villains especially the dark triad
they are my favorite like they're just
so intimidating so scary so the idea
that it's permanently ending is a bit of
a surprise
but i will say one thing though a lot of
people might not be surprised by this
because
if you look at where the manga is right
now in terms of chapters compared to
where the anime is
they're actually not that far apart
you'd like i reckon within like 10
to no within like 15 to 20 episodes
i reckon the anime would have caught up
fully with the manga
so it's not it's not a surprise in that
aspect but what i thought they would do
is maybe announce a break
maybe you know going seasonal um but
judging by this announcement
they're fully cancelling it like they're
not they didn't say we're gonna be going
on break they fully said like you know
the the last episode it'll be coming to
an end on march 30th not the end of the
season
seems like the end of the series i don't
know this is very uh
upsetting news definitely like um we'll
see what this big announcement is
obviously the movie is a possibility
but i will say this if they were just
going to continue the anime like
next year or something why save that for
a big announcement why not just straight
up say
black clever will be going on break and
we'll be continuing next year like
to me it's probably not a continuation
it has to be either a movie
or or something i don't know what else
could it be you guys let me know in the
comments
now moving on the official black clover
twitter account put this video up
which was accompanying the message that
the series was coming to an end and
if you can you know if you notice you
can see yami is the main focus of this
video
so it's kind of implying that yami's big
battle will be the end of the series
although i'm thinking about the the
intro there was a character in that
intro
that wouldn't get introduced until after
yami's big fight
so maybe the series is going to end with
that character being introduced
um although that would be a bit of a
tease you know to introduce a character
and then immediately stop the series
so you know what maybe i reckon that
character will be introduced whoever
they may be
and then a couple maybe one episode more
of him and uh and whoever he interacts
with doing their thing
that's just my estimation but we will
see let me know what you guys think of
this cancellation like are you surprised
by this
i definitely i'm surprised because i
didn't think they would straight up
cancel it
i knew they would have to do either
filler or you know go on break but
i didn't think they'd announce a hard
you know this is the end of the series
type thing
um so i am surprised but uh again this
is the way it goes
be sure to drop this video a like if you
liked it and until the next one
peace out